la france marqué par la brutale
agression le week-end dernier du maire
douche cette petite commune en côte d'or
des élus de plus en plus souvent
victimes d'incivilités
selon l'association des maires de france
2 133 mer ont été agressés de janvier à
juillet 2020 contre 198 l'année d'avant
à la même époque et les chiffres réels
pourrait être encore plus important
d'après la mf
car beaucoup de maires ne vont pas
systématiquement jusqu'à la plainte pour
en parler on va tout de suite retrouve
sur loire philippe b chaud il est maire
de saint philippe d'aiguilhe est lui
aussi a été victime d'une agression
c'est le témoin direct de la matinée
[Musique]
mais
suit les baies show bonjour bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france alors je le
disais vous avez été vous même un
victime d'une agression c'est en août
dernier vous avez déposé plainte après
cette agression qui vous a valu cinq
jours d'itt et et il me semble
racontez-nous qu'est ce qui s'est passé
we've écoutez c'est donc le 4 août
dernier j'étais on m'a signalé les
habitants ont signalé qu'ils aient vécu
du bruit sur la sur la place publique
une première fois vers 19h30 j'ai pas
prêté attention c'est l'été joueurs de
pétanque des jeunes me dit on et puis
vers 22h30 notre habitants les enfants
ne pouvons pas dormir
bagis eu lieu devant ses joueurs de
pétanque pensant ce que des jeunes puis
en fait je n'étais pas des jeunes la
nuit était tombée ou tel en train de
tomber avec les éclairages publics
j'étais à contre jour j'ai pas vu qui
c'était je me suis avancé je suis
présenté mais j'ai donné et on dirait ja
a à ce qu'ils baissent la musique ce
qu'ils ont fait ils ont même arrêté mais
bon il était le groupe 2 qui si donc les
as de colisée qui a acquis à qui n'a pas
accepté que je viens de leur dire
d'arrêter la musique et est le chef de
2,2 le chef de cette communauté a pu
tenir c'est sûr mais qui pendant un
certain temps secours - oui à abandonner
et là je me suis fait agressé et tabassé
par un seul individu tabassé à terre ou
deux points et tout ce que vous imaginez
bon là j'ai eu des jours de rtt
cette agression que vous venez nous
raconter quel impact elle a eu sur votre
quotidien mais aussi sur votre façon
d'exercer votre mandat alors sur le soir
le soir même quand j'ai passé la nuit à
l'hôpital
je pensais j'ai pensé abandonner parce
que je me dis je suis pas élu pour ça la
tène d'années que j'étais
lui c'était la fin de vos le début de
mon deuxième mandat comme maire j'ai dit
non je suis pas je suis là pour aider la
population pour faire ' bénéficier mais
habitant ce parce qu'on pourrait leur
apporter et puis là sinon et finalement
à point d'inflexion avec mes enfants du
heureusement été là c'est les vacances
j'ai pu j'ai pu j'ai voulu médiatiser
parce que c'était quelque chose qui
tenait qu'était qui était insupportable
donc j'ai médiatisé mais d'autres mais
qu'il venait d'être agressé ou keita
blessé quelques jours après il est juste
un rappel à la loi
donc quand vous avez une agression comme
ça bon le temps se passe le temps
médiatique balle et le kop le quotidien
reprend et vous n'êtes pas comme avant
et donc j'ai eu un suivi psychologique
que je me posais beaucoup de questions
j'ai l'impression de partir ouganda au
toucher et et venons pas dans un état
normal qu est en fait quand vous avez
une agression comme celle ci vous avez
avant et après et effectivement
aujourd'hui
là je ne suis pas comme avant j'ai
énormément évolué je je je vous
expliquais je ne suis pas j'ai changé
mes centres d'intérêt et aujourd'hui tu
veux plus être abattus aujourd'hui j'ai
envie de de puiser ses sets c'était une
agression la force pour mon territoire
pour développer tout ce qu on peut
développer sur la commune à
l'intercommunalité watch hawks et j'ai
changé j'ai puissance menaçant que
d'altérer mon métier
quelque part je m'abandonne parce que
baisse est plus petit que ça que j'ai
changé sa sagesse en charge un homme
comme on dit la charge demandant comment
est ce que vous avez réagi à cette
nouvelle agression s'était dit mais ce
dimanche dernier de ce maire de la
petite commune nous écouter c'est là
vous bien évidemment je suis extrêmement
extrêmement sensible allégations
malheureusement collègues touche pas je
lui écris très très simplement pour
messieurs l'assuré mon soutien et
ponctuellement lettre que je puisse lui
apporter aux vues manman'm à leur
expérience ça à chaque fois qu'il ya une
agression
évidemment tous les souvenirs remontent
les haies et j'ai envie je me dis menace
pourquoi on en arrive à ce stade la
taille veston en plus en images dans le
dos à pardus perd 7,8
beaucoup des gens comme nous nous sommes
tous tout ça à la retraite que la
retraite mais voilà on a j'ai un
sentiment de deux je suis je suis
accablée de cette violence la violence
des mères mais la violence est policier
la violence de toute cette jeune femme
est assassinée ces derniers jours dans
moselle je crois voilà c'est une
violence
lloris en pointe alors que nous mais on
est là où justement gérer le quotidian
donc tout se passe bien et on a toujours
toujours toujours cesser ses agressions
et sa remontée sa romance est vraiment
c'est comment faire comment faire là je
vous avoue que certains peuvent en dj
plan des pistes perso mais eux justement
après votre agression est ce que vous
avez pris des mesures est ce que vous
avez réfléchi à la façon dont vous à
votre niveau vous pouviez lutter contre
cette délinquance
alors si vous voulez j'avais le 5 mai au
matin c'était extrêmement une affaire
qui était extrêmement médiatisé j'étais
pas encore entrés l'hôpital que tous les
journalistes étaient déjà à la mairie
devant mon domicile
bon
et je me suis posé la question je me
suis entretenu avec mon avocat avec mes
enfants je me suis dit qu'est ce que ce
qu'on fait est ce qu'on réponse
correspond pas évidemment j'ai souhaité
médiatiser comme vous dites leur pouvoir
est bien la mère qui avait été agressé
deux jours après mois et qui était juste
un rappel à la loi donc ça ça m'était
insupportable
donc je suis très jeu qu'on dirait j'ai
beaucoup de famille politique de de tous
bords des parlementaires et on a
souhaité dans un premier temps essayé de
m'amener à alerter le pouvoir aussi bien
que de la somme nationale du sénat et de
ce fait le premier ministre et autres on
essaie de les alerter soutenait ces
choses qui sont inacceptables et
malheureusement moins de paris le
comider temps là je n'a pas pu faire ce
qu'on aurait pu imaginer à témoigner de
notre quotidien de merde petit village
engelures aux doigts ou ailleurs et
amont afin qu l'on n'a pas pu vraiment
on n'a pas fou de faire je sais que des
réunions ont eu lieu au niveau de la
justice je sais quelque chose culture
rappelons qu'ils ont bougé mais je peux
dire le mal est extrêmement plus profond
à ce que c'est
est-ce que c'est l'éducation est ce que
c'est je sais pas vous voyez c'est
est-ce que vous comme au maire de votre
petit village comme vous dites est ce
que vous avez observé au fil des années
finalement une augmentation vraiment
visible de la délinquance non alors si
vous voulez ce qui s'est passé c'est des
gens comme en extérieur commune il n'y a
pas de nos villages de délinquance il
peut y avoir quelques pizzas civilité de
jeux ou autres qui sont extrêmement
marginale et qu'ils sont plutôt pour
vous expliquer des choses qu'on a nous
aussi tout être fait quand on était ton
était jeune on a par rapport au village
peut-être une périphérie ou des trafics
et au truc
andré de la délinquance mais on peut pas
dire qu'il ait vraiment de l'un des deux
l'a de la délinquance pure ce que nous
mais nous avons envie de lâcher de
régler des problèmes de voisinage de
comportement sûr pas forcément qu prier
à la vie en société
des choses comme ça c'est pas de la
délinquance pure comportements ont
évolué désistement est ce que vous
observez que le comportement de vos
administrés a pu évoluer il ya plus
d'agressivité aujourd'hui dans notre
société
oui ça c'est bon le voir le voit partout
eia alors en ce moment est ce qu'il ya
des chèques aux vite peut-être mais
effectivement on se rend compte de
conflits d'usagé je m'exprime ainsi
parce que nous sommes un milieu viticole
et je suis tic heures et sont donc des
traitements pour un contre les maris de
la vie et nous avons des nouveaux
habitants nous avons des gens qui sont
plus réceptives à côté environnement et
vous l'aï su créer des conflits et 7,7
s'est construit n'existait pas il ya
quelques années
alors voilà donc il faut qu'on arrive à
trouver des justes le juste milieu en
qu'il faut traiter bien sûr pas je
dirais polluer notre environnement
pollué de la vie de nonne automne aux
habitants les gens sont ne supporte pas
la tondeuse les gens' pour pas le chèque
divague voilà c'est ce genre de de
comportements qui ont tous les jours
quasi non tous les jours on obligé de de
faire de faire face et de trouver des
solutions à ces problèmes là
heureusement aujourd'hui on a un
artifice qu'est le conciliateur la
république donc on essaie de faire
rencontrer les les personnes qui sont en
conflit au point de ce ce conciliateur
de justice parce qu'ils sont plus à même
que nous de gérer ces problèmes là merci
beaucoup philippe baijot d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin sur rtl france
je le rappelle vous êtes le maire de
saint philippe d'aiguilhe
giraud monde